I have some bad climate change news from
both the North Pole and the South Pole
first in the South Pole in Antarctica
scientists have been watching a growing
crack in a major ice shelf called Larsen
see which is slightly smaller than
Scotland it's a 350 meter thick ice uh
metre thick ice shelf that's floating on
top of ocean waters and the crack has
grown to 30 kilometers in length from
2011 to 2015 and widened by 200 meters
in the last few years and in the last
six months alone this is accelerated
even further growing another 22
kilometers in the last six months it may
only be a matter of time before we see
the loss of a huge chunk of Larsen see
this would be a historic event this
would drastically impact the oceans it
would not be good it would be yet
another sign of the very quickly uh uh
drastically negative effects of climate
change the amount of ice that could be
lost would be around 6,000 square
kilometers now that's the South Pole in
the North Pole things are not really any
better scientist Peter wadhams believes
that the summer ice cover at the North
Pole is about to disappear triggering
even more warming of our planet he also
adds that most people expect that this
year we will see a record low in the
summer ice cover this has huge potential
impact and it impacts the entire planet
up one issue is what's called albedo
feedback sea ice reflects a lot of solar
radiation back into space water reflects
very little ice reflects about fifty
percent of solar radiation water only
ten percent so you might say okay yeah
well but ice ice up in the North Pole I
really care that's not going to affect
me well not only are we talking about
sea level rise due to melting ice but
we're also talking about significantly
more solar radiation actually staying
here on our planet and whenever we talk
about melting sea ice Jason there the
climate deniers who say David people
have been scaring us about the no sea
ice in the North Pole
during the summer for 10 or 15 or 20
years and we still have some every
summer we have less every summer and
there's no indication that that trend is
changing so I for me when someone says
but that's been predicted for a long
time and it hasn't yet happened well
we're getting closer every single summer
rrr you suggesting we wait until there
is no sea ice whatsoever before we take
action it seems insanely short-sighted
yeah all these climate deniers are just
you know ostrich's ostriches keeping
their head in the sand pretending
nothing's gonna happen I'd one thing I
like to look at or I have looked at in
the past there's a story about Mont
Blanc and France in these glaciers there
and you can see things the eighties the
nineties you know that zeroes than the
teens and it is not even there anymore
and you know just 30 years ago is this
massive glacier with huge rivers and now
it's it's almost almost drought status
there yeah and it you know as an
individual bringing your own grocery
bags to the store and biking to work
that's fine right but uh uh and and to
the extent that it makes someone feel
like they're doing their part I support
that and if everybody did that that
actually could make a difference but
we're talking about a planet with
billions and billions of people here and
we need major major change I'm not
laughing off people who bring their own
grocery bags to the supermarket I do it
myself but what I'm talking about is
that we really need way more of a sense
of urgency here